ich weiß man das macht es ja muss jana
bach und und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen folge eine challenger jetzt
einfach nein ich erkläre es ist okay und
zwar wenn einer von uns runter fällt
beim checkpoint bei jedem checkpoint ein
wechsel erster tipp bolt dann hat und
das muss man sagen dass wir mit
sebastian steuerung spielen die reihe
ist leute schreibt man die kommentare
max hat glaube ich man kann so nicht
spielen wir müssen die steuern ein
doch du kannst du spielen kannst du
spielen romano macht schnell
max hat einfach sprinten auf steuerung
und ziegen auf shift ist das sinnloseste
es ist die standard minecraft einstellt
und es ist scheiße zu höheren alters
macht kennt wie soll ich denn hier zu
spielen ich muss aufs nicken können
denkt um das denkt ungefähr ja ok
anspruch ist es irgendwie sowas wie
schnell wir hatten sie art mensch dass
du scheiße da ihre fünf sekunden
hereinkommt okay sie einfach nach jedem
parcours steuer umstellen so jetzt
machen wir das mal ganz nah dran ball
gespielt keiner sagen was ist immer gut
aber über den raum war es nur skill
werde über die genauere glück ist auch
nicht die ja genau
eine kombo gekommen so wie genau ich
habe einfach nur eine combo com jetzt
bin ich schon wieder down alter zeit
mich schon wieder depri gemacht danke
schön du stolz verrät ausprobiert ist es
mal so von thomas in dem jetzt auch mal
gefällig
ja gut ist ja nicht mal ausrücken muss
jan [ __ ] sie verkauft sich einfach
gut herr sprung muss dies an den rand
schaffen weißt du wo kommt all access
mit einem master komme ich mit einer
steuerung locker machen
mach jetzt ansagen ärger mit max ich
habe erst das lehne ich mich hier gerade
komplett aus dem fenster lehnen
doch jetzt mal auf dem grab bringen
spielst du im moment fällt vom leben ja
ich habe das immer drin der warteliste
des blind disziplin
woher zug noch erreichen
nee ich mag halt ein bisschen diesen
einrichtungen ich mag ich mag ein
bisschen diesen alten minecraft stil so
ich habe hat viele alte halle games
folgen von gut gefallen und ich mache
mir diese alten stil oder passt dieses
paypal ganz gut 1 2 3 4 linien ist das
nicht ja doch kommentiert einfach und
man muss schon ein bisschen umdenken
aber ja genau
einfach weil sie live wie schlecht das
gesagt du machst das so doppel handicap
erstmalig ein detail ja ideal du bist
allerdings in die cap land bestellt ist
alle neuen vorschlag ist das einfach top
3 wieder spielfreude
das ist schwierig hier das schwierig ist
ob torwart
ich spiele einfach uns nicht nennen aber
es geht nicht guck guck mal wie ich
daran denke wie man es nicht oft wird
meister
wir sind so richtig partner des senders
bitte bitte bitte lass mich sterben ja
man und jetzt nicht daran natürlich
nicht daran
ich nicke 25 23 sieg über rock trifft ja
ich das bei jedem abstürzen aber es wäre
noch mehr bei jedem absturz war schlimm
alter die im portfolio welcher leute ich
bin einfach so
leider ohne witz ich bin einfach so neu
ist dass ich auch mit maxis spielen kann
ich bin mit dem körper auf platz zwei
hätte sogar fast 1 cargo hat als
einstiger ist auf unserer höhe
champix einmal so nein es wurde so ein
nachspiel
ich habe das beste spieler jede ninja
blick also jeden youtuber ok ansage nein
aber ich glaub den job ich bin ich schon
einer besseren keinen schädigen wenig
run spielen dagegen warten www habe ich
auch schon abgezogen
damals in seiner template woche als er
noch richtig gut im training war habe
ich in abgezogen du hast ihn eingeladen
ehrt dich ein gerissener begannen auch
für mich da nicht reden
gronau ja du bist auch abgestürzt hat
eine drecksarbeit tatsächlich sieht der
parcours bisschen gleich aus wir haben
so nice einfach geholt
warum nicht aber ich dass ich noch
spielen kann
weißt du noch damals im juli den cup
dreimal ausreichend urlaub da hat mich
youtube videos machen wir uns immer
abgeschrieben mit zwei games spielen
abgespielt hat uns ja direkt alles war
aber nicht die österreicher südtirol
dass ich sogar gleich ganz anders ist
roche hat gleich behindert alles klar
der besondere an dieser stelle einen job
er vergisst manchmal jetzt zuhört also
wisst schon geht es weiter
hey wir sind ben heppner von dpa die
staaten geklungen wie dieser parodie wie
sagt es auch wirklich genauso aber gegen
habe ich das ist auch gespielt gewann
ich heraus gespielt weil hauptmann
leistung gekommen ist auch nach wie vor
seien vereinbar ist oder nein erst
meiner es kam ein livestream rein aber
du bist mein ohr judith kamps leisten
wollen
eur und weist ja geil
denn die schnauze als ob alt ob du
glaubst sich wirklich er glaubt wirklich
dass ich das ich sag dir du schaust du
nachdem ein video an nicht übertreibt
nicht aber ist kein held leute hat jeder
so seine eigenheiten
ich muss einfach das machen bitte du
kommst hier könnt ihr mit ihr können ist
den gewinner also zumindest vom ersten
platz finnischen das geht gar nicht
komplett ich hatte mir das macht es ja
muss merkel einfach und jump jump jump
einfach überhaupt nicht weil ja ja ich
hab ich hab's einfach wenn's regnet es
auch immer ja vielleicht ja weiß ja nie
was kommt was wirklich so leute ist
bisher übrigens war ist bald in den
urlaub oder ist schon für morgen
ich weiß nicht wann es kommt für die es
heute ja ich sehe sieht es heute auf
youtube ein junger spieler mit einer
mango steuerung ganz ehrlich das ist das
allerletzte
damit jeder nebendran jedem spiel
ich sag dir in jedem spiel ist sprinten
auf shift in jedem
außer in minecraft minecraft scheiße man
aber die kiste
ich hätte ihn auch geholt hatte wir
müssen erstmal wir machen an wechsel
noch drei kids ab
ich glaube einfach ins bett und ich
backe fig dein leben nein nein ich nehme
ja auch noch weg weg das ist letzte
nacht hatten genau drei kills alles klar
sie warte ich mir meine angel die straße
mein feind und so weiter was du brauchst
du nicht aus der ferne zu entfernen
nur weil du gab es im hässlich geworden
bist hat den dreck fressen sie einfach
nachdem ich so genial rasiert haben als
man sieht der definitiv weg
degas ist einfach kacke minecraft
onlineversand sofort gehen sofort weg
privates antrag sonderklasse war
erwartet dann drei zwei eins kopf jetzt
machst du mit seiner levy steuerung
alter ist oder war es ist einfach es ist
lächerlich
es ist lächerlich der kleine zoo seines
lächeln ich finde es irgendwie witzig
mit einem schwäbischen folge stieß die
ganze zeit über so richtig am schmollen
so voll scheiße das ist voll scheiße den
dermaßen recken in karlsruhe aber wenn
es nicht ein schlimmer karlsruher sc
jetzt hätten wir dagegen alle gegen ihn
ein lautes dauern ich habe getötet aber
noch uci ja dass wenn dadurch noch ok
die anmache wunder dass ich habe spaß an
meiner maus hat dass ich direkt auf die
angel abbas dass ich mich umdrehen kann
ich konnte mich gerade mal fünf junge
5 i sie dafür habe ich eine flache
tastatur ohne wirtsleute ich finde
flachetappen alter
ich finds echt besser wenn die tastatur
so flache tasten hat für seine
genauigkeit seiner die schnauze halten
hasst man besser darüber greifen kann
ein drechsler maxis rocket die übrigens
das zehnfache von meiner gekostet hat
nicht kann ich nicht so gut spielen
größter brocken an dieser stelle weil
die einfach viel zu gut hass hat jetzt
bist ich lasse mich daran dass ich mich
daran zu lassen
du hast drei cas gemacht die unter weg
ich finde jetzt stücks ich höre jetzt
stürzt ich kenne so hart du möchtest du
bist deutlich abgemagert junge deswegen
wollte ihn nicht spielen lassen weil er
weiß klar wann du hast einfach zeigt
wird es zwei decks gehabt der neue hatte
ich überhaupt ne doch würdest den ersten
direkt ja 29 war einigen und dann sind
es 22 ich werde in die kommentare
während heute hat der markt lasten